vingt-cinq ans après la guerre froide il
est difficile de saisir toute la peur
qu'inspire et les armes nucléaires dans
la région de tahoua un vestige de cette
époque permet d'en avoir un aperçu
l'abri souterrain secret construit pour
protéger le gouvernement canadien en cas
d'attaqué nucléaire a été transformée en
musée
daniel thibault la visite est à une
quarantaine de kilomètres du centre
ville d'ottawa intérêts vague quelques
structures et ce petit garage tout à
fait anodin le début d'un intrigant
corridor bienvenue aux défuntes banker
labrie qui avait été construit pour
abriter le gouvernement en cas d'attaqué
nucléaire construit dans le secret entre
1959 et 1961 un énorme complexe
souterrain qui s'étend sur 4 étages
c'est grave c'est immense et à peu près
sans mes pieds carrés de superficie si
on est qu le tunnel en tueur s'est pas
bâti comme une semaine en france et ça
et ça devait tenir à l'époque 515
jusqu'à 535 personnes pour une durée
d'un jusqu'à 30 jours une petite
communauté complètement isolables du
reste du monde est parfaitement autonome
avec ses génératrices ces systèmes de
filtration pour l'air l'eau ces dortoirs
son dentiste même sa propre salle
d'opération ça date de 1959 mais à
l'époque c'était vraiment exactement ce
qu'on retrouvait dans les miens
meilleurs hôpitaux dans londres les
architectes avaient tout prévu
oui alors le réfrigérateur ici sera
utilisé comme morgue
si jamais quelqu'un serait mort durant
une période de confinement de bout à
l'autre du complexe tout le nécessaire
pour que le gouvernement puisse
continuer de fonctionner et ça c'est un
peu le centre nerveux du banc que
essentiellement oui exact que ce qui se
passe alors c'est surtout utilisé pour
la récolte et l'analyse d'informations
faut faire un peu d'ordre du désordre de
qu'est ce qui se passe à l'extérieur du
bon coup de reins garnica que c'est très
important de relier cette information au
cabinet
pour qu'ils puissent pas avoir décision
défensif et pour rester en contact avec
la population dans un coin du niveau 3
cents à une douzaine de mètres sous
terre un petit studio de radio canada
cilicie ça aurait été la seule façon de
rester en contact avec les canadiens en
cas d'attaqué
ici fait la suite du premier ministre un
coin du banquet un peu plus confortable
mais les privilèges ont des limites
urbaines
le banquet est entré en service en 1962
des militaires y ont été postées 24
heures par jour pendant 33 ans il n'a
été en état d' alerte qu'à deux reprises
fermée en 1994 le banquet est devenu un
musée quelques années plus tard et si
daniel thibault radio canada ottawa